thank you very much thank you
and welcome to siblings conversation
with Salman Rushdie I want to just begin
by by explaining that in March of 1992 I
interviewed mr. Rushdie for the first
time it was near Dulles Airport I had to
meet a stranger at a hotel bar who would
take me to his secret location I'd know
him by the fact that he was carrying a
Wall Street Journal and we had a lengthy
interview by my standards and I went
back today to read what Salman Rushdie
said in that interview and what I said
in introducing it and I realized that
what I wrote 20 years ago is equally
true today here's what I wrote there's
one thing I'd like to say about some and
Rushdie before anything else and that is
that he wrote Midnight's Children a
brilliant novel about India that had me
in stitches several years ago for that
book alone I would want to interview
Salman Rushdie and would probably even
go to some out-of-the-way Hotel and meet
some designated intermediary and then go
somewhere else to do it needless to say
mr. Rushdie is no longer famous we're
simply writing good novels and his
popularity is not the reason for such
bizarre arrangements he is famous
because his later novel The Satanic
Verses was deemed blasphemous by the
late Ayatollah Khomeini who issued a
religious edict they fought why it's
called condemning Salman Rushdie to die
since then for the past three years he
has been in hiding in Britain mostly
protected there by the security police
so here's what you told me in the
interview in 1992 he said I really think
that before this year is out this thing
will be over
your your pseudonymous alter-ego Joseph
and Anton Joseph lived on for quite a
while long it was I was just 10 years
wrong just 10 years wrong what was it
like being frustrated thinking this
thing was about to get settled the fired
office could work something out and then
being dashed all the time right I think
that the problem of how long it went on
it's very difficult to write about
duration it's very difficult to write
about the fact that it wasn't that there
were people shooting at me through the
window it wasn't you know it wasn't
dramatic it was just this sense that it
was never going to end
he just went on and on and on which is
why I used somewhere in the book this
this image from from Boris that
Argentinian writer where he talks about
the Pampas in Argentina and he says you
know you this is something you can't
take a photograph of them if you take a
photograph of the pump bus they look
like a field that's it the only way you
experience them is by traveling through
them and then they just go on and on and
on and on and on and all and they're
always the same and they go on and on
and they're always the same and they go
on and on and on and they're always the
same and that's what it was like it was
like it was like being in that situation
of a thing of a situation that just
endlessly went on and during that time
you could not live in your own home you
lived in the company of the police yeah
yeah that was I mean you know a lot of
people thought that I was in sort of
isolation somewhere but actually it was
the opposite of isolation I was living
with four enormous men with guns and the
word close friends
I mean we became quite close yes but it
was it was sometimes the problem was not
isolation with claustrophobia yeah and
you managed to write and it's eventually
up and down yeah I mean I think the
thing that saved me was that I'm
actually that I'm a novelist you know I
think if I'd been a playwright supposing
the Satanic Verses had been a play you
know or a movie if I'd be in a movie
director
it would have been virtually impossible
for me to continue with my profession
you know because of difficulty of
getting a play put on or a movie made
but writers are used to sitting in rooms
and staring out the window and wondering
what the hell to do yep there you are so
so in a way I had I was trained for this
you know what what you what you said
about the Bohr cases image of the
pompous the never knowing when it's over
it reminded me of a sensation in New
York right after 9/11 it was a with
hindsight we can say there was a moment
when we knew that had happened yeah but
for a couple of days we didn't know
there could be another plane something
something could go on one doesn't know
in these things Robert there are many
ways in which would you experience seems
to foreshadow things that we all came to
experience well I mean that's you know
that's what I very strongly came to feel
that what what happened the case of the
Satanic Verses was a harbinger you know
it was a prologue in some way and I
think that's one of the reasons why it
was so often so badly understood when it
first certainly in the West why it was
so badly understood because we had no
narrative to fit it into you know it
seemed to come out of nowhere this sort
of strange medievalist attack you know
using accusations of things we hadn't
heard about since the Spanish
Inquisition you know heresy apostasy you
know these crimes and people thought
what the hell is this and then though it
was easy for people then to think
well we don't understand this because
it's all kind of weird and foreign but
he understands it and so if he's upset
them all so much he must have done
something really bad yeah and it was
very easy for people to do that because
as I say they didn't have a larger frame
and what gradually happened over the
next decade next 20 years was that
people began to understand the larger
narrative and of course the 9/11 attack
if you could say is the main event let's
talk about this idea that that some of
you are detractors I guess and one thing
we learn is that if if we're ever
targeted by a fatwa death sentence and
are consigned to safe houses every
perceived flaw and our character will be
published in the in the media and time
yeah if you're if you're history just
flows in our character flows in our
appearance just everything well it was
argued look you you wrote daringly about
an area where given the state of
leadership in Islam in 1989 you were you
were knocking on a door that was
certainly possible some ogre would come
jumping out of it
you you pays your money it takes your
chances yeah well that's a plausible
argument isn't it except that one of the
seems to me one of the greatest things
about the history of literature is that
writers have always taken on ogres you
know writers have always in every
country in the world taken on tyrants
and pointed out they've been called them
by their name you know that when model
Sam wrote his poem but Stalin he knew
perfectly well who Stalin was and what
he was like yeah you know lorkhan
ooh-hoo-hoo Franco was such I mean it's
a the history of literature is of poets
and artists writers standing up and
telling the truth about tyrants to their
face and and it's what are the noble
things about literature just say that
that's what you must do is to diminish I
think what writers have done that we we
have a stake in the in the right era of
fiction
feeling defended in being courageous and
taking on ogres yeah I mean is it
Shelley said that writers are the
unacknowledged legislators of mankind
which may be putting it a bit high right
but then he's a Romantic poet no but I
think it's that speaking truth to power
you know that that business of saying I
don't care who you are here's what I
think of you but [ __ ] is a good thing
would you is speaking truth to power in
in a very important way and in the it's
the imagination of the artists being
free to speak truth to power an election
wasn't going to depend on your getting
this scoop you weren't going to call out
the government for its lies it's
something very different from that yeah
also you know the Satanic Verses wasn't
even primarily a novel about Islam
because it was the most of it was a
novel about migrations a novel about
people coming from the Indian
subcontinent and settling in England in
the 1980s and the consequences of that
and in the middle of it there's this
dream sequence no there's this dream
sequence in which there's a prophet not
called Mohammed inventing a religion not
called Islam in a city not called Makkah
and this is a dream and it's a dream in
the mind of somebody who's going insane
now this is what we in the trade call
fiction yes
that is giving that word that would be
the technical term for it um but instead
are one of the strangest accusations of
all the strange accusations it was
leveled against me but from quarters of
the Islamic world It was as if there's a
suspicion about fiction itself but the
fiction was being proposed as being
something which conceals the true
motives of the writer so whereas most of
us who practice it think that fiction is
a way of revealing truth not concealing
it but anyway the I heard it a thousand
times people said he is hiding behind
his fiction your real agenda yeah my
real agenda is concealed in this
fiendish make-believe you know and I
thought this is this is really one way
of describing it is that it's a category
mistake you know it's it's people
reading fiction as if it's simply
disguised fact and so for instance in
this dream sequence when this religion
is being born and there are adversaries
abusing the newly faithful you know in
jeering at them you know which happened
I mean it was the year the early history
of Islam it was persecuted worker so how
do you do persecution without showing
the persecutors doing the persecuting
can't do it so and then if the if the
things the persecutors say when they're
persecuting the persecuted people are
accused the author's accused of agreeing
with them right that he means what they
mean suddenly you realize what they mean
by disguising fact by fiction because
they they it was the assumption that I
was on the side of the persecutor if you
could put those words on paper clearly
yeah clearly was what I must mean them
you must mean them yeah and so this was
a it was a kind of surrealist experience
I kind of I mean I often think that of
the three the Great Trinity of 20th
century writers who invented modern
literature which is Joyce Proust
Kafka you know it seems to me the Kafka
is the one who got it most nearly right
but we live in the Kafka ask no and one
of the characteristics of the Kafka ask
is that at the same time as being dark
and scary it's very funny and I remember
I used to say to my friends at the time
that offer notes I said you know if this
stuff wasn't not funny at all
it would be quite funny no I mean for
instance quite soon after it all began
there was this interview that I saw on
British television with a rather sweet
looking elderly British Muslim leader
who'd be one of the organizers of the
demonstrations and you had another sweet
silver silver beard very neatly trimmed
and so on and soft voiced gentle elderly
bloke you know and the the TV
interviewer said to him had he read The
Satanic Verses
he looked shocked no said now I know is
it of course not and the gel and the gel
interviewer said well this is not mr.
Rushdie's first book you know in fact
it's his fifth book and and he's written
a number of telev
use paper articles and short stories and
so on and so on have you ever read
anything that he's written and this gent
sweetly disarmingly with this kind of
gesture
he said you know books are not my thing
see burning books however burning books
with you you know we should get to this
the you know your your your global
adversary or a global pursuer and this
was the Ayatollah and Iran but within
Britain the very members of the very
immigrant wave that you'd been writing
about yeah organized a book burning
people seemed at least comfortable with
the idea of a vigilante death sentence
against us incident had the benefit of
clergy and in some outright endorsements
of you know he should die for this was a
domestic British issue and you at one
point and that the site guesses the
point of greatest regret for you you sat
down with a group of the other leaders
of this movement and it's a very vivid
scene you describe in a very special
police station I want you to well um
well Paddington Green police station in
London is the sort of maximum security
police station that was basically built
to interrogate and house captured
members of the IRA so it was built as a
kind of terrorist holding station and
this was the place where I stole was the
only place I would be allowed to meet
these people and I mean look the point
is I was in a very bad state of mind I
was very this is about two years into it
about late there's Christmas 1990 when
this was Christmas Eve
I think 1990 and first of all I was very
worn down by the endlessness of it and
that was only two years you know also I
was very worn down by this public
rhetoric that was getting louder and
louder in England I mean partly from
conservative politicians partly from
bits of the you know the news media and
but also even for the public at large
and there would be these these opinion
polls published in which substantial
majorities of British public were of the
view that this was my fault and it was
up to me to do something
to fix it you know you broke it you fix
it you know all this pressure really
took its toll and that's what a lot
suckered me really into this meeting
with these Islamic worthies who claim
they could sort it all out if I would
just have a meeting with them and make
friends yeah and when I arrived there
they showed me this very badly typed
piece of paper with spelling mistakes
and no grammatical errors things that
offend me I don't think this is the most
clever way of appealing to your vanity
about the confession you had to write it
from that point I said look you know
it's not grammatical right all right and
they said no no you can rewrite it
you're the writer
yeah you see yeah I thought yeah that's
so I am and but the problem is that in
this text that they had constructed was
what they consider to be the price of
the ticket which is that I had to make
this declaration of religious faith
which was clearly absurd because now I
have less religion than you could
inscribe or a chewed or fingernail and
and yeah but not you know weekly and and
shamefully I got I got I was just so
desperate to break this logjam that I
signed this document and immediately
that I left and that immediately I was
whisked out of the police station and
taken away in the armored cars and I
need I'd realised I'd done something
very very stupid I felt like I'd ripped
the tongue out of my own throat and I
told lost my language and and I'd you
know and I'd lied and and I began I was
almost I almost threw up at the back of
the police car which was I'm glad I
didn't because the windows didn't come
down because yeah because they're all
this theater anyway it was a bad moment
for me it was kind of like I think in
its it's described in the book as being
the moment of God hitting bottom and I
think it was
in retrospect I came to think of it as
beneficial to me because I think you
know it was it was a very clarifying
moment it showed me something that I
hadn't looked at before which is that
there was no way of making everybody
like me yeah you know that that there
was nothing I could do and that actually
it was dangerous to try and make
everybody like you because it led you
into the into a trap it led you into
areas of compromise about things that
should not be compromised about and I
just at that point thought the hell that
is just the hell with it
I'm not no more appeasement no more
apology no more atonement no more saying
I'm really sorry you know [ __ ] it and
but I just think from that moment on I
in a way it taught me how to fight you
know and instead of it just told me just
stand up for it just stand up for your
what you've done and what you believe in
and what's right and if people don't
like it they don't like it and so
although it was an awful moment for me I
mean really sickening moment in my life
I think out of it came it will be out of
it but it blood blood Lee came the
person that I was able to become so
there we are
yeah back to some of the the the
difficulties of living as you did yeah
under under protection which often
verged on confinement another of 9/11
parallel for those who wonder did we
give up much of our freedom in order to
be secure in the threat of terrorism
well you were being told routinely I
don't think you'll be allowed to do that
it isn't you you may not go visit him
your son can only come here under these
particular occasions you're being
protected but protection meant great
curtailment of you well well also the
truth is that every single of a person
in in England who received police
protection
received it by living in their own house
you know they didn't have to go
underground in some way you know they
lived at home and the uniformed police
protected the property and the Special
Branch secrets with police you know
looked after them when they went about
their daily business and they went about
their daily business you know there was
no attempt to say you have to disappear
and except for me and I've often thought
that I made a mistake you know that I
mean if I've had it to do again I might
just say you know what I've got a house
over there I'm going to I'm going home
you want to protect me oh that's where
you'll find me yeah you know I mean it
would have been more dangerous but maybe
maybe would have been able to be a
little more dignified baps it was just
how dangerous it was the best you could
do was to learn that somebody had had
critical credible information that there
had actually been a plot somewhere ya
know that I mean did happen several
times I mean I did go you know one of
the strange things about this as I got
into some very strange places I mean I
actually went into that building on the
terms which you see in James Bond movies
you know what Judi Dench is inside with
an odd with him but with si si yes the
head of the Secret Service is called si
anyway yes and I met all these people
and actually I came to admire them quite
a lot I mean I thought they were really
smart and really tough and really knew
what they were talking about and I
thought that it was quite good in a way
to have them on my side you told me 20
years ago at the strange hotel near
Dulles Airport that you found these
people sophisticated and interesting and
I talked with him and you would kid them
but you would write the book that would
blow the lid off the life of the secret
police yeah there are a few moments in
this book when you talk about the the
ease with which someone whose life is
entirely secret and goes off to
undisclosed places to protect
individuals they can't describe it's the
perfect cover for having extramarital
affairs yes right one that was indulged
in by your accounts pretty often whether
we should ask dick cheney's the other
person who was at undisclosed location
oh uh but yeah it was it splits perfect
cover perfectly fooling around
yeah honey I've got to go away on
business it's really secret I can't tell
you anything about it
and when I come back I'll have nothing
to say no I can't tell you where I'm
going and I won't be able to call you
and I'm gonna be away for eight days
sometimes some of your protectors did
yeah they did they did you say some its
factory was probably all all I see is it
roughly all of them there was one while
I could tell you about because he got
thrown out he got fouled out had thrown
out of the police but there was one of
the guys who was with me for a while was
a bigamist yes he had he had two
families two wives to chill sets of
children and he'd taken the precaution
of giving both wives and sets of
children the same loving nicknames
sniffing there's no risk of forgetting
never make a mistake
wherever he went he called them whatever
he called gas he only got caught because
he was not a very senior police used us
to detectives inspector tentative
sergeant I think and and he was just
getting into debt so they caught him
because he was broke got into debt but
not but otherwise he was he was cool in
addition to the the real life building
where the fictional character M works
yes you have surgery at one point you
needed a you needed abet achill
treatment yeah I will add I had a
problem with my eyelids which is the
medical problem whether its condition
called ptosis where basically how much
do you want to know about it well you
needed surgery okay you can just say it
begins with a pea and people can look up
to us yeah the muscles that work your
eyelids stopped working properly
yeah and so your eyelids just come down
and eventually they don't open at all so
I had to have this repaired and went
into this hospital and then nervous and
I mean wasn't an operation on my eyes it
was only my eyelids but nevertheless I
was in this place with my head bandaged
and came out of the surgery in the
middle of the night and said hello and
nobody answered I said hello
and nobody answered I thought what a
[ __ ] I didn't know where I was
yeah etc and and he just happened to be
like I picked the the moment I'd pick to
emerge from anesthesia was the moment at
which the night nurse had gone to the
bathroom so there was just nobody there
but it was an extraordinary moment just
it was just having a minute or some two
minutes but to be blindfolded and not
know where you are and not even know
what condition your eyes are in it was
it was a moment and and in a very
special Hospital
I gather very it was a yeah it was a
very well everything's irregular
everything I did was it some kind of
maximum-security place where you know
the royal family and they would have
their surgeries have their surgeries
there
don't ask what the royal family
surgeries are they don't if you don't
want to know this is a this is a memoir
and it's not just the story of you and
trying to get the Satanic Verses
published in paperback which was quite a
struggle little talked about but it's
also about your life I mean at the
beginning of this saga you you had one
wife and one ex-wife by the end of it
you had had four ex-wives one of whom
deceased by the end of the story at the
beginning you had one young son by the
end of it he's a young adult and you
have another son yeah I mean you're a
lot you were living a to put it mildly
an active life even under within this
shell of protection nature that you're
having you know there was this as this
moment when I 1990 somewhere where I was
interviewed by Mike Wallace for 60
minutes he came to whatever undisclosed
location yeah and and at that point it
had just become known that I had
broken up with my then wife Mariana is
and so like the second question the 60
minute sir the second question he asks
is so your your marriage ended I said
yes and he says what do you do about sex
it's a very highly rated program 69 oh I
thought I thought this is the most
important political show or American
television the second question is about
[ __ ] so what you know as it happened
I had by then through great good fortune
met Elizabeth West who became my wife
and was a mother of my youngest son but
I wasn't gonna tell Mike Wallace that
you know because it it was one of those
magic moments where the right words just
dropped into my mind and I said well you
know Mike to tell you the truth I'm
really grateful for the rest ha ha ha ha
and he looked he looked so shocked that
I had to say something like you were
just kidding I anyway that's Mike
Wallace at me Nick now in addition to
your your your family about life
changing quite a bit over this time
during that time you wrote the more his
last sigh you're at the ground beneath
her feet hmm I think you're at The
Enchantress affiants late late July
wrote I wrote the first one I wrote was
her in a sea of stories and right and
yeah and that the collection of stories
east/west didn't yes projected um and
I've you know I wrote I wrote yeah I did
my job and as I say I really think that
the fact that I was able to do my job by
just sitting in a room and writing was
an enormous part of what saved my life I
could you know I could be myself I I was
trying to figure out whether I thought
you're how much your writing was
influenced by the experience
yeah and it does seem to me that the
mores last sigh celebrating in memory
Moorish Spain and
Mendota great cultural cooperation
between Islam Christianity and Judaism
is that is that Sun something of it
that's something of it but you know what
that book really came out of is a was
something else and what was what was
growing in India at that time was a lot
of not in Islamic but a Hindu fanaticism
the rise of a kind of extremist Hindu
nationalism and one important aspect of
that was was to raise the issue of
authenticity what was an authentic
Indian and and that the Hindu
nationalist answer was it only the Hindu
experience of India was it was
authentically Indian and what that meant
is all the minorities of course the
largest minority being the Muslim
minority were in some way inauthentic
right and I found that very annoying and
so and so I thought that I would take a
very small Indian minority which is the
South Indian Jewish community and then
create an even smaller minority by
having somebody from that community
marry into a South Indian Catholic
family thus creating a Catholic Jewish
individual who is probably a minority of
one person you know in a country of a
billion people and then show that you
could actually grow the whole experience
of India out of that one person you know
so that everybody in India is
authentically Indian so I would say you
know and not just any particular
devotional group
and I mean the novel the novel came out
of that desire just to to rescue what it
was to be an Indian and from the from
the spurious logic of this kind of
attack yeah we you talked earlier about
literature and the role of the the
writer the fiction writer and at the end
of the book there's actually a wonderful
pianta literature that you that you
write and talk about the the important
purposes of fiction this this raises a
question well that that came up in a
kind of a public feud that you had with
john lecarre ii at one point in the
pages of the Guardian which is is the
freedom of expression the the domain of
the literary artist or I think his his
phrase was does the person who writes
Pulp have the same the same freedom of
expression would i would given the
experience of recent weeks broaden that
totally the completely artless trashy
video yes sir
who writes something that may even be
calculated to offend who knows now do we
all have that same unit of speech
includes freedom to to speak crap yeah
you know it's not only for artists it's
also for garbage makers you know like
that like the what say whatever his name
is akuto i don't think he even knows
what his name is yes is it but it's it's
often the case when you're fighting this
free speech argument that you find
yourself defending stuff you don't like
I mean there's an episode in the book of
something that happened to me which is
there was this film made in Pakistan in
the early 90s called international
guerrillas which was about a group of
what one might now call al-qaeda
terrorists whose job was to find and
kill me and and when they did so that
would be the happy ending right right so
now the the character the me character
was shown living what looked like an
island in the Philippines indicated
protected by Israeli so texted by the
Israeli Secret Service you know all
writers have these whole
homes and at one point remember there
was a one of the international guerillas
gets captured by the Israeli Secret
Service it gets brought and near the the
me character is depicted as having a
bottle of you know Jack Daniels and run
hands or swinging way like that in the
other hand is like either a whip or a
civet Rd with which he you know Lakes
his idol lust on people because that's
the kind of guy I am
and and anyway so the the member of the
heroic international gorilla is tied up
between a couple of palm trees like this
and and I'm there to you know torture
him and then I have a better idea then I
say to the Israeli Secret Service yeah I
said take him away and read to him from
The Satanic Verses all night and of
course he totally cracks you know you
know not about anything but that this
Pakistani movie this movie like British
which is hugely defamatory and sword in
the end of the film I'd you get killed I
don't get killed by them I get killed by
flying currents unleashing bolts of
lightning right right you know you know
personally fried by the Almighty right
you know I thought what there's dignity
in that you know anyway
the film gets banned in England films
refused a certificate because it's
defamatory and because the certifying
body is told that if they give it a
stiff gift yeah I can sue them to for
defaming me so I have I decided I can't
do this I'm fighting a free speech
battle I can't be defended by an active
censorship so I have to write to the
British Board of Film classification and
formally give up my right of legal
appeals I'm not gonna sue you so please
give don't not given a certificate on my
account so they did it opened in the
biggest cinema and Bradford which is the
largest Muslim population in England and
where they did the book burning yep
anyway big cinema have this kind of
outsides of auditorium and nobody went
why because it's a really crappy movie
yeah yeah and and whether or not people
liked me or not they didn't want to hand
over their money to go and see a really
bad film and I thought it was a great
little microcosm of the argument for
free speech which is if you had banned
that film it would have acquired glamor
it would have acquired the glamor of
taboo bit of a banned object and people
would have been watching videos behind
drawn curtains you know etc you put it
out there it disintegrates but I mean I
suppose the proper parallel would be if
you knew that all of the novelists in
Britain would rise up and riot once this
came out if you knew that Penn
International would which would order a
death sentence to the filmmaker one can
begin to understand the the the sensor
is interest in keeping this there the
idea of rioting novelists I know you
know it's I just put that to you as a
kind of a fictional concede you know
that's it's that's that's the odd that
stretches the browns of credulity but no
look yeah here's the thing we seems to
me we can't we should try and not live
in a world in which the threat of
violence is what determines what we can
say are not saying you know otherwise
we're giving in to the men of dialects
and I mean I think this is a lesson we
learn in the school playground you know
if you if you give in to a bully you
ensure that there will be more bullying
not that there will be less there will
be more and and the only way you defuse
bullying is by standing up to the
bullies and I think you know we know
this when we are kids we should remember
it when we're adults having exceeded
having strain credulity with my image of
riding that I'd still imagine imaginary
trying to imagine Martin Avis and Ian
McEwan exactly exactly
no no looting race you're still smashing
windows yes having shown that I'm
clearly out of questions I'm going to
turn to the questions that the audience
has submitted and put them to you as
several of them anyway why do you feel
it's now safe to do this tour well
because I've been doing this kind of
thing for 11 years now and so far you
will seem not that dangerous
but when the when the Moors last I came
out you well it wasn't me but those days
it was still there were still a lot of
security around no I mean 2002 really
March 2002 is the is the last moment at
which there actually was a security
presence in my life and then since then
you know I've been on the lecture
circuit I've been teaching I've been
speaking at universities have been you
know going on the Jon Stewart Show it
doesn't see well that's dangerous anyway
no I mean it's it's the thing to explain
to you is that the the real danger to
not just my life but to all those who
remember the fatwa also named the
anybody was involved in in the book at
all certain included publishers
translators booksellers etc the real
danger was never from like random
violent individuals the the danger was
always state-sponsored terrorism it was
it was the paid professional assassins
of the Iranian state and it's been its
proxies that was what the danger was and
that was and there were some attacks now
there were no there were a number of
attacks yes so in one attacks on
bookstores over those bookstores in
America they would like Cody's bookstore
but in Berkeley California was
firebombed
there were there was a bookstore in
London there was firebombed twice
there were bookstores all over the world
that were attacked and not just burned
but actually people going into
bookstores and threatening people
working there and in publishing
companies and then well the great
tragedy was that the books Japanese
translator professor hit Osheaga Rashi
was murdered at his university in Japan
and there was an attempt to murder the
Norwegian publisher book William me
guard and the Italian translator of the
book Petter a Caprio who both
fortunately survived but this was you
know this was a shooting war and the
point is that in all these cases the
evidence that emerged showed that these
were not these were these were these
were professional hits this was not
spontaneous range from the local no no
these were professional hits and and so
basically the danger was very high until
this moment in the toilets around the
turn of the century when when we finally
managed to get the Iranians to back down
and at the point at which we were
convinced Urton that they actually had
stood down these these gangs of killers
really most of the danger which way
perhaps you've answered this next
question what is the difference between
the fatwa and the recently announced a
bounty on you well how do you how do you
deal with that well the battery has been
though it was not recently allowed to be
in there all the time the fact is that
nobody's a most recent nobody's ever
taken this old gentlemen seriously even
in Iran because it's pretty clear that
he doesn't have the money you know
anybody could stand up and say about
three million dollars but if you don't
have three billion dollars it reduces
the force of your argument and no this
is you know what's happened to me in
this decade since the spring of 2002 is
it every so often somebody in Iran Stan
been sort of wakes of waves of fist in
my direction and says something rude
yeah but it's as I hate the differences
between this form of rhetoric and the
actual very dangerous situation of
professional hit squads yeah and and and
historically in Iran the people who were
okay with the fatwa include the former
reformist President of Iran the man who
some people think won the election and
had it stolen from the most recent yes
all of them a dinner judge I mean even
that's one of the problems with Iran
isn't even the Liberals are [ __ ]
yeah it's the novelist imagination I
can't I can't indulge in that from my
line of work here's a question this is
now now for something completely
different or us I in your opinion what
would you say is the most critical
crucial element whether literary
structural or moralistic to an engaging
children's story oh I can tell you the
answer to that um
because because it's what my when I
wrote her in the sea of stories it's
what my son told me I failed to do i
when I'd written about three thirty or
forty pages I thought I better show it
to him to make sure it was going all
right you know so I showed it when he
read it and and when I talked about it I
could see that there was just some
little cloud on his face you know and I
said what do you like it and he said oh
yeah dad I liked it dad I said so what
do you not say and he said well dad some
people might be bored and I said he said
he said not me of course you know I'd
read it but you know
some people and and I was shocked and
displeased and I said bored that's the
one bore what do you mean bored why and
he said this wonderful thing he said
well you see Dad it doesn't have enough
jump yeah doesn't have enough jump in it
jump in it jump I understood exactly
what he meant little jump so I can do
jump let him do that back you know
grabbed it back from him to wedge it
back when went away and rewrote it with
with extra jump extra jump and and then
gave it back to him and now through
gritted teeth said what do you cigarette
now and he said no doubt now it's fine
yes you know and it was like it was the
best most precise literary criticism I
ever had because it was actually really
helpful
yes you know so that's it the secret
ingredient for writing for that well
this is not exactly children but so the
young adults is jump jump if you have
jump the rest of its okay
alright ask JK rowling Gigi has can you
tell your favorite story about oh you're
very you're very good friend of late
Christopher Hitchens oh alright it's
kind of very it's actually very strange
for me
still to come to washing Washington and
have him not here because you know every
time I would come here I would stay with
him yeah and you know it's a bit it's a
big it's a big hole in the world I mean
I just tell the story about the silly
games we used to play all these games
right I invented the clean ones and
Martin Amos invented the dirty ones
you're the sanitizer yeah yeah the clean
one was you know what there was well we
had different games we used to have Bob
Dylan quotation marathons uh-huh and you
know I I would try and recite the whole
of visions of Johanna and he would try
and recite the whole of sad-eyed lady of
the low lads and see about Christopher's
he had the most amazing retentive memory
so he always won those
are you we invented the dis get this
game about titles of things that didn't
quite make it so you know a farewell to
weapons farewell
you know mr. Shivaji oh was it mr.
Chicago yeah yeah two days in the life
of advantages of it and you know for
whom the bell rings
there were lots of these Toby dick volts
also known as moby prick did Oh
blueberry Finn
blueberry such anyway that was then
Martin Martin and he invented hysterical
sex that hysterical sex game is where
you replace the word love in the titles
of things with the word with the phrase
hysterical sex so this gives you
hysterical sex in the Time of Cholera
you know all you need is hysterical sex
hysterical sexes of many splendid things
that make it into the book I catch my
toe and thinks oh my gosh so did you did
you end and Hitchens talked about you're
a bad yeah becoming American about about
settling in this country was it
something that you you talked about
explicitly or just was the fact no it
just was a fact I mean that but the
thing that happened with Christopher
which is what I should say is that is
that at the in 1989 at the time of the
football
we we were friendly but we weren't close
friends you know covered he lived in DC
I was living in London and we had lots
of friends in common we saw each other
when we could but he wasn't like one of
my bosom buddies at that time when this
happened to me he was beyond to say was
outraged was to put it mildly I think it
became a very profound event in his life
and he just took the decision to come
and stand right next to me and be one of
my closest friends and he became my
friend because of this
and then of course became mother most
wonderful allies that anybody could have
you know in Christopher's a the fighter
you know and and if you're in a fight
you want him on your side you know you
said he didn't want him on the other
side he peppered and so it became our
friendship became closer and closer in
those years because he wanted it to be
because he wanted to to make that
statement you know and I thought that
was extraordinary of him I mean I came
when I came here to DC to go to have the
finally when it was arranged me to have
a meeting with Clinton III actually
service went to the White House from
Christopher's apartment and he had been
quite helpful in pressurizing some of
the people he knew in the Clinton
administration like George
Stephanopoulos for example to try and
get the meeting to happen and and was
and even though you know Christopher was
no great fan of President Clinton yeah
to put it mildly yeah
hated his guts yes and I yeah
but thought that it would be valuable if
I could meet him and so really tried
hard in fact George Stephanopoulos was
so excited when the meeting finally
happened that he called Christopher from
the White House while I was having the
meeting with Clinton and said
Christopher the eagle has landed
yes this is it so I think the only time
I ever had anything in common with Neil
Armstrong it was like it was felt like
landing on the moon yes
um one small step etcetera but it was an
important meeting that because the
previous American administration the
george bush senior administration had
been very dismissive and uninterested in
this matter and suddenly to have the
American government the you know putting
the power of the weight of the United
States behind this and saying there has
to be a solution first of all it
stiffened the spine of a lot of other
European and other Western governments
and secondly I think it got the
attention of the Iranians and and the
combination of that and the initiatives
of the New Labour government in England
finally brought the thing to an end so
it was it wasn't a big turning point III
guess in fairness we should say that the
when a reason was given to you for why
people would not stand up it always
involved hostages who have been held in
the interracial Iranian surrogate you
were in the hoppers somehow with Terry
Waite the Archbishop of Canterbury's
emissary and the America I mean actually
fire you know when there were American
hostages in Lebanon that and initially I
was I was asked by the US authorities
not to visit the United States while
there were hostages in Lebanon because
there were negotiations to get them out
and they didn't want to endanger them
and to be fair that the day that the
last American hostage was freed and
brought to safety the Americans said to
me there was no longer problem I could
come whenever I wanted so in that sense
they kept their word actually met these
see this is the thing about meeting
strange people there there is there's an
official I don't know who does the job
now but that there isn't as an official
in well probably in Washington who is
the US counterterrorism chief right now
that that is an official which holds the
rank of ambassador but his the job is so
secret that while he is doing the job
you can't say his name you can't say
where he lives that you can't you can't
describe any of his movements and and
yet he runs the whole counterterrorism
operation of the United States and I met
three of them these invisible men you
know and and I mean I could write one
hell of a spy novel yeah but anyway it
was one of them who had asked me not to
visit the United States and was another
of them who then said ok I could come
and then I actually was able to come the
first time I came here not here New York
was to speak at Columbia there was a
event celebrating the Bill of Rights the
anniversary of the Bill of Rights and I
mean this is one of those funny funny
although not funny moments because I was
met the airport by an 11 vehicle
motorcade
with at the center of it and an armored
white stretch limousine you know it was
like having a huge finger in the sky
baby she could original he's here she um
and there was a police officer in charge
of this operation dude in the book I
call him lieutenant Bob I said to it I
said we tell it Bob this is a lot I said
wouldn't it be better just to put me in
a secondhand Buick and drive me through
the back streets of Queens you know he
looked at me you know pity eglee and he
said no sir it would not be better and I
said I said well who else would you do
this for and he said sir it's it's what
we do for Yasser Arafat so I suddenly I
was the head of the PLO you know and
it's like a level of treatment the
Arafat suite yeah yeah so I said I said
just because I was curious I said well
if if this if you were protecting the
president I mean what more would you do
because this already looks like a
colossal amount right and he said well
sir if if you were the president of
these United States so we closed down a
lot of these side roads here sir and
we'd have men up in the buildings there
and we probably have some helicopters up
there sir your case we didn't do that
because it would look too conspicuous
it's very good by the way do good good
American um one of our guests at one of
our I guess in the audience asks did you
believe at some point and I guess from
your story that point would have been in
the armored car back from Paddington
Station did you ever believe at some
point that it was not worth writing The
Satanic Verses no I mean that's when you
which I thought it was more or less not
worth living I mean I look the thing
about the Satanic Verses that I'm very
proud of it I mean I think it's one of
the better books that I've written and
and
and I think I think also one of the one
of the reasons having gone through all
this and fought this fight so that we
could reach this moment now when now
that the fusses died down people can
finally read it just as a novel you know
other side thinking especially of
younger readers I mean if you're like 30
or under now then you would have been 5
or 6 or less you know when this happened
and it's ancient history so I think
younger readers could come to the book
sort of carrying less baggage if you
like they can just just pick it up and
read it see what they think of it and
that's beginning to happen and and so
and now I find some people love it and
some people can't stand it and some
people think this and that but that's
you know it's no longer freighted with
the whole exactly it's a man's life was
at stake
no it's finally having the ordinary life
of a book and I think you know I'm happy
for it and I think I mean here's the
other thing I really think it's
important to say is that books survive
if they survive because people like them
not because people don't like them you
know it's a scandal vanishes you know we
don't care about the literary scandals
of a hundred years ago 200 years ago any
book that survives for any length of
time it survives because people think
it's valuable people you know and every
book literally any book that stayed in
print a hundred years has stayed in
print because people love it
you know not because people don't like
it and so now finally this book has its
chance to see if it's going to pass that
test no and I mean I won't be around but
at least it's got a shot now you know I
did I liked it that we talked about my
because I've been around a long time
that Midnight's Children which is now
more than 30 years old yeah you know
people still seem to think it's worth
reading and so I mean there's people you
know who weren't born when the book came
out who read it now cetera so that's
like leading the first hurdle you know
going into the next generation if you
could do three four more of those then
you've got a chance of sticking around
well I was thinking about this in
reading the Joseph Anton that at some
point there will be
literature professors who will assign
this book and have to explain the huge
hoo-ha that surrounded it yeah and this
may not be evident from anything you're
reading in the book right now exactly
but here is here is how this book
figured in the history of the world
circa well now they can read this other
book which explains there you are there
you are then
I don't actually one of the one of the
things I really I really feel is that
you know for a long time I didn't really
want to talk about all this stuff
because you know if I would write a
novel and I would come on the book tour
to talk about my novel inevitably
somebody would want to ask me about the
vampire and all that and I would get
frustrated because I would think you
know I'm here to talk about this novel
so for a long time I resisted talking
about it and so now suddenly another
oddly I'm doing nothing but talking
about it but I also think it's a way I
hope it's a way of drawing a line under
it because you know in future if I'm
here to talk about a novel and somebody
asks about the fat man I'm just going to
throw a 600 page book here go raise yeah
go read that very no and that feels I
mean just feels good to have it out in
the open and one of the things that
feels good we were saying before we came
out that all these people helped me I
mean so many people helped me it helped
me in the most extraordinary ways
sometimes literally moving out of their
own homes so that I could live in them
because I needed somewhere to live and
none of us has ever told the story you
know and it's been two decades and we've
all kept the secret and this is this is
the literary world this is this is the
world that can't keep a secret to save
its life these are people will have this
is like got essentials yeah exactly
but you know to save my life everybody
zip their lips didn't say one word yeah
you know where to actually extend that
still further you say that when all this
was over you concluded that one of the
reasons you're a secret had been well
kept
was that the workmen who worked on the
house and fixing it people actually knew
this Salman Rushdie said and they didn't
talk labour is suspected who this was
and they didn't
everybody just thought this is really
serious don't screw up yeah you know
everybody like focused the and and it
was an extraordinary act and I've often
thought I think more and more really
that that yes there was this this kind
of hatred level that me and my work such
a but there was also this extraordinary
collective act of solidarity and
friendship amounting almost to love you
know and I thought if you what happened
in this if you like was a battle between
love and hate and you know and the
reason that I'm here is because of the
is because let's be corny because of the
power of love you know which actually
proved itself to be stronger than the
hey
here's a question which may if I'm using
the the idiom correctly beg the question
yeah with the rise of Islamic extremism
how can Western society maintain an
unbiased and respectful view of the
religion I wouldn't recommend it you
wanna ask a follow up way that's the
Hitchens answer that's the Hitchens act
approaches go make a cartoon instead but
I mean since not just millions hundreds
of millions billions of people believe
devoutly in faiths which are
fundamentally incompatible with one
another yes could not believe all of the
revelations that have been north that
have been received it can be argued that
one way that we keep the peace very
broadly is either to live in separate
countries and never migrate from one to
another or to just not go to certain
places and - I mean intellectually not
raise certain topics not apply the same
rigor to someone else's faith that we
would to their clothing well but that's
chicken there's no this chicken but I'm
offering it to you just a second is it
well also be polite I mean there's
another word yes but you know democracy
is not a polite thing yet how do you
noticed yeah I mean one of the things
about living in a genuinely open society
is that people disagree violently all
the time when I say violently I mean you
meet you don't mean I don't mean violent
that's the problem I mean they disagree
but the nature of democracy is
disagreement yes and very often that
disagreement is extreme and very often
as we see in this country today
it's very hard to see what common ground
there is between people on one side and
people on the other you have a very
divided nation yeah you know but I've
come to believe that that the argument
itself is freedom you know you don't
have to resolve the argument you just
have to be able to have it and in every
country which is not a free society
the argument is shut down somebody says
you can't talk about that yeah or worse
we will tell you how to talk about that
and if you don't use the official way of
talking about that we will come after
you and get you but but there are
throughout Europe in countries which
Americans may dismiss as being
undemocratic but who seems to be
functioning democracies there can be
limits on some kinds of hate speech and
yes that goes far beyond our standard of
in science which is you know yelling
fire well I would you know I would I
mean I you know in England where I lived
a long time there are greater limits I
mean for instance there's a thing called
the race relations act which which makes
it illegal to make racist remarks yeah
you know whereas here the First
Amendment would actually defend protect
the Ku Klux Klan or whoever making its
its various forms of viral remark and
you know you can argue both ways but my
the view I've come to have is that the
First Amendment is a better way to go
because bigotry dreadful ideas do not
disappear if you prevent their utterance
you know and those ideas sometimes
actually increase in power if you ban
them and force them on the ground and
it's better to have them out in the
light of day you know vampires die in
the sunlight um don't you have to drive
a stake for the you don't even have to
know okay I didn't know how you know it
even has easier than I thought is
doesn't know it's just it's just let let
the light shine in the one of our one of
our members of the audience asks is
interesting in the age of social media
and the internet well is do you think
the Muslim world is at a crossroads how
easy is it for anyone to whip them into
a frenzy or for that matter I would add
how different would all this have played
out in the age of of the Internet
well me I think I think it would to be
much more dangerous yeah I mean in those
days the fastest communication device
that existed was the fax machine if you
remember
the fax machine and there were
telephones which had cords that
connected into the wall and that was it
you know I mean I remember they like is
a sort of funny scene in the book where
you know where I wasn't I when I wasn't
allowed to give out a phone number to
people etcetera and I had this friend of
mine who worked in the computer business
yeah and he said to me one day he said
he said you know there are these things
now called mobile phones and maybe you
could have one right and then people
could call you and they wouldn't know
where you were how innocent that is yeah
and I said oh god that sounds fantastic
and he said I'm going to look into it
mmm-hmm and a while later he came he
brought me this object that was like you
needed a little bag to carry his record
this huge brick you know but it was like
magic
I wasn't connected to anything and I
could push buttons and people would be
there and it really I mean you have no
idea what it felt like it felt magical
because suddenly I could give out a
phone number no I think if the internet
had existed and everything else you know
text messaging Facebook Twitter all that
just it would have been so rapid the
spread of the attack would have been
instantaneous what about the there's a
fiendish problem of how to get
publishing houses behind the the
paperback edition where people were
afraid of what would happen even if
someone had come to you today and said
we have a secret origin online which
will go straight to the logo straight to
the Kindle edition yeah across the
e-book I thought that would be easier I
mean certainly the invention of the of
digital books would have would have
solved the problem because the reason
why there was such a fight about the
paperback what the reason why I was so
anxious that there should be a paper bag
is that we all knew that if you want to
keep a book in print over any length of
time
you have to have a cheap addition you
can't have the original hardcover
edition because no matter how popular
the book is there will be a moment at
which people stop buying the expensive
hardcover edition and if then you don't
have a cheap Edition the book will go
out of print and since we were trying to
fight for the right of this book to stay
in print we needed a cheap Edition and
that that was the argument that I was
using with penguin books in which sadly
they were unable to support and so we
had to eventually do it another way
now yes you could have an e-book and it
would achieve the same end but you ran
out during that whole argument you ran
up against the well the argument that
hadn't you you know so point is point is
taken you had the book is published yeah
now this will all go away if the book
isn't once again published this time I
know well this is all you see the
arguments backwards the argument is that
somehow the book is the problem and if
you just forget about the book the
problem will go away but the book wasn't
the problem the attack on the book was
the problem you know and it's very
important I think not to get this upside
down you know it's okay for books to be
controversial it's okay for books to be
things which many people disagree with
you know this is the reason why when you
walk into a bookstore there are a lot of
different books there by different
people
I noticed that that's you yes I mean
they're not unfortunately all by me
which you know I mean I would prefer but
there we are the point is that you can
choose to read to read the books you
want to read you know and and to decide
that a book by simply by existing not
because you're reading it and are upset
by it but just by its very existence
it's such an affront to you that you're
going to try and burn the world down
yeah but that's the problem not the book
I think we have since we started late I
think we have week a little time again
but more to go no that was yesterday
wanted to go home I'm sorry you can't go
huh no no we get your to do another ten
minutes a little bit more the Nationals
game is over so you know it says you all
know the result it's not good okay there
is a question about was it a single
event that made you come out of hiding
for Android or very small events many
small events yeah it was that it was
step by step I mean I mean in the end
yes there was a there was a particular
important event which was the
negotiation between the British
government in the Iranian government
that happened at the United Nations
Security Council not Security Council
General Assembly in 1998 at which the
Iranians agreed to withdraw the threats
and after that there was a period of a
couple of years when the British tried
to make sure that they were telling the
truth and had withdrawn the threats but
essentially that was the big event but
before that there was a kind of step by
step thing that you know I mean I was
pushing very hard to be allowed to just
do ordinary professional things that
writers do such as touches with the
Mausolus I came out to be able to talk
about my book to my readers and things
like that and a lot of this was a battle
with security forces internationally
gradually we got a little more
cooperation little more and so that got
bent a little bit I mean the thing that
really I have to say this the thing that
really made a big difference to me in
those years was this country because
America allowed me to come here for
periods of time which started off being
short like a week or ten days and ended
up being much longer like two months two
and a half months at a time and live
here an ordinary free life you know it's
a it's a
so I was allowed to make my own choices
you know I was allowed to come here and
just decide what was okayed what was not
okay what was sensible and what was
stupid etc and this could rent rent a
place in New York City or in upstate New
Yorker and Long Island or whatever it
might be in and just live and so it gave
me breathing room it gave me a way to
come out of the bubble and begin to have
again an ordinary life and and with with
my wife and children and so on as well
no and it was incredibly important and I
think it's you know it's very much the
case the reason why when everything did
get finally better that I made a home in
New York City where I've now lived for
almost 13 years is because this was the
place where I began to get my freedom
back here you know in the end that made
me feel fond of it yeah you also it was
not only with their countries that
thought it would be ill-advised for you
to visit and wouldn't let you in at
various times yeah their airlines that
yeah not yes oh you know yeah yeah there
were I mean it was there was for long if
for a long time it was difficult to get
on a plane at all and again you began to
judge countries by the behavior of their
national airline you should have so
Britain Britain didn't come out very
well written no no no did America
actually the United States not good at
all Canada Canada yes yeah Scandinavian
Airlines yes
Air France you know these are all
interestingly these are all countries
which have a long history of concern for
human rights yeah and interestingly that
spread into their airline I mean to the
point was
the airlines but the point is that the
airline I gather was persuaded you do
describe one small almost comical scene
about this that people upon seeing you
in an airplane would get up and walk off
what will happen I'm not gonna fly a bad
guys it happened the ayatollahs after
him exactly what happened once once yes
it happened once and it was one person
right and I was terrified that the rest
of the plane was going to get up and
walk off you know it whereupon I would
have been screwed yeah um but no it was
this one person but I mean I'm worried
about that but actually what used to
happen was the opposite yeah was that
people would come up on planes and say
are you okay and we've worried about you
and we're concerned for you you know
actually human beings the generality of
human beings are very nice no and people
showed a lot of that kind of surround of
applause for Humanity or a good luck for
a good species yeah all you faceless
people at the dock yeah yeah most of you
are very nice except for you question I
should have asked you at the outset why
did you write Joseph Anton in the third
person know when his life could only be
yours well it's your story but you write
about him about yeah well I mean the
answer is because I tried to try to try
tried to get in the first person and and
I didn't like it I mean I you know
obviously I thought it's autobiography
write it the first person you know and
and I started off and I just didn't like
the tone of it all this too much me me
me me shut up you know and but I also
there were some other reasons first of
all I had this idea of wanting to write
it like a novel I wanted to write it
with the skill of the novelist except
that everything is true and I felt that
if I have if I'm describing myself as I
and everybody else as he or she then the
I character is somehow separated is a
different kind of character overly
privileged character than the he or she
but if even the me character is just one
of these other third-person people then
I can write about everybody at the same
level if you like and that that helped
me
the other thing was I was trying to
suggest that the person the self that I
was writing about it's not exactly the
same as the self that's writing the book
I'm partly because the self that's
writing the book has already gone
through all that experience and come out
the other side and hopefully learn
something from it and digested it etc it
is reflecting and looking backwards and
is much older by the way you know I mean
when this whole thing began I was 41
years old you know in I'm 65 so I'm
writing about this the choices and
decisions and actions of this much
younger self and I just and also it's a
younger self that's under colossal and
sometimes deforming pressure and stress
and a lot of my friends would say to me
when this all ended you know when I when
I was in my 50s people would say you
look younger now than you look ten years
ago and I mean I if I look back at the
photographs I think so too I mean I can
see the weight that's on that person you
know anyway so I wanted just to say yes
I'm writing about myself but but it's a
slightly different self and and so it's
it just became easier for me as I say I
didn't like the eye and there was a
particular day but I thought let me just
see what happens if I push this into the
third person you see what it feels like
and the moment I did it I it was like a
it was it was like a light bulb moment I
thought oh I can do this
this I know how to do I found as a
reader I got over it pretty quickly
that's what people say people saying are
the first two or three pages you think
what and then then you stop thinking
that yeah you know when you say when you
speak of the stress and the the feeling
looking having looked older than than
than 10 years later was it was it your
relationship with your son that's eating
at you most is it the fear that your
whole life could be spent surrounded by
security a little it's all of that I
don't know I don't know how to rank it
but all of that and just frustration and
claustrophobia and and of course the
feeling that this could end really badly
at any moment
it's range thing there's a there's a
there's a moment in the Moors last side
that the the main character there's a
paragraph somewhere way he's talking
about the nature of fear and he says I
mean I'm paraphrasing because I can't
remember exactly but he says something
he said that fear is a is an absolutist
he says with you know with with fear
it's all or nothing
you if you give in to fear it's all you
can do you could just be afraid and and
I felt that I thought there's a certain
moment at which if you actually want to
do anything at all I mean including
write a book be a father to your son do
anything you have to find a way of
putting the fear to one side it doesn't
mean that it doesn't exist it doesn't
mean that you're you don't need to feel
afraid it just means that in order to
have your day you need to put it in the
corner of the room you know and it was
interesting to me because I was thought
that when we were talking about the
Lebanon hospitals a lot of them when
they came out said something similar
about about that in order to handle fear
you had to put it away and do something
else you know and and I felt that that
the way of surviving this was literally
I had this image that I would put it in
a little box and I would put the Box in
the corner of the room it didn't mean it
wasn't there it was there but I just was
going to look over there I was going to
look over here and have my day and I
mean it's a mental trick but it's
something that I I tried to do so I mean
I don't know which of these things was
the worst you know but I wouldn't
recommend it any of it
if you could possibly avoid this I mean
one of the things I thought yes the
thing about I really feel pleased that I
finally got a [ __ ] good book out of
it
anger because because at least that at
least that at least that because the
thing about this you know it's a spy
novel it's a thriller and it's got you
know full of these wonderful
existential dilemmas that the elite
character faces yet that's got all of
that I mean the point is now that I'm
here able to write about it I can think
as I thought about the Satanic Verses a
good story it's direct but at the time I
thought if possible don't live through
this story you know if you could
possibly avoid your life be like this
you should but we appreciate the the
news we can use in that in that in that
case I said at the outset then when I
interviewed you at was the West fields
the West Hill you were if not the only
guest in the hotel at least been one
wing of it I think they had sort of
sealed off a hold it off walking I
remember walking on this long corridor
with my colleague the recording engineer
with just police at key points and then
the room at the end and then the entire
elite of the American media yes
you know you Terry Gross Charlie Rose
Mike Wallace all kind of arriving
blindfolded be led by the felt being led
by men holding the walls feature was as
I said we with that day I got to have
from my experience from my usual
routines a relatively long interview
yeah I think we spoke about 25 minutes
yeah perhaps ten of that got on the air
of 15 so by that standard I feel I feel
absolutely honored tonight by having
this much of your time and being the the
questioner so you have written a
terrific book it's a plot no one could
have thought up though and and I've
enjoyed it and and talk with you about
it thank you thank you Tom